-Our next guest is the
Emmy-winning writer and creator
of "The Sopranos."
His prequel film
to the iconic series,
"The Many Saints of Newark,"
is in theaters and on HBO Max.
Let's take a look.
-Where is he?
-Downtown.
-He's downtown, where he might
get burned to death?
What are you people thinking?
-[ Crying ]
-Janice, shut up with that!
W-What were the two of you
doing at that card game?
-Dad took Janice to ride the
rides while he played cards.
But he wouldn't take me
because I pass gas,
so he was eating lunch.
-Get inside, both of you!
-Please welcome to the show
David Chase.
Welcome, David.
How are you?
-I'm okay. How are you?
-I'm doing wonderful.
I love this movie.
I, of course,
was a huge fan of the show.
When you were making it,
did you think to yourself,
"This is a reward for
all my fans"
or "this is an entry point
for new fans"
or did you just have
a story to tell?
-Uh...none of those.
-Okay.
-Warner Bros. wanted to do it.
And they had been
coming to me over the years.
And, finally, like 2018,
it sort of worked out,
the timing was right,
and we came up with the story.
-A lot's been written about how
younger generations
are finding this show now.
I -- When I first
watched it when it aired,
I thought of it very much as
a show about the Mafia.
And then I rewatched it with
my wife, who had never seen it,
and I felt it was a show about
a marriage
the second time through.
What are you
hearing that younger people
are being drawn to
about the show?
-I don't know.
I hear a lot of
different things.
And then, yesterday,
I finally had a lightning bolt
hit me that it's not PC,
and they don't get that anymore.
And it seems like, "Wow!
Did you hear what he just say?"
I think that might be it.
And the characters
are also un-PC.
-Another thing that I feel like,
if you never watched the show --
And I think part of this --
I don't know what
you think of this theory.
Because of the way
the show ended
and how much, then,
people put into
trying to take apart and
understand how the show ended,
people forgot that
it was a deeply funny show.
And I'm wondering if
first-time viewers
are so surprised by that,
because even I'll admit,
I kind of forgot,
until I rewatched it,
how there was never an episode
that wasn't full of
comic moments.
-Well, all I can say is
that I didn't real--
I didn't -- I made a statement
to the effect that
I don't know whether
it's a drama or a comedy.
But that didn't really
hit me until, like,
the show was almost over.
That's when I realized.
-Were you guys --
When you were writing it,
were you laughing a lot
as you were working on the show?
-Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah.
Yes, we were. We were.
I mean, those characters
were just great, you know,
pieces of clay to work with.
They were -- You know,
Tony Sirico's funny,
just period.
Everybody was, really.
A.J. was funny. I don't know.
It was just -- it was just fun.
It might have been the casting,
really, that did it.
-Well, not only do I --
-Junior was a riot, you know?
-And the casting
not only was great,
but I would imagine,
the longer you wrote it,
the more fun people would have
writing the characters,
Because you -- I mean, you must
have just gotten to know
them as the show went on.
-Yeah. I heard that from
some young woman
at one of the events we went to.
I said, "What do you guys
see in the show?"
And she said, "I don't know.
You come home from work
into your apartment,
and it's all dark
and you're exhausted.
You turn it on,
and there they are.
And you feel relaxed
and like you're home,
like you're with your family."
As far as I know,
that's what television
has always been, right?
In the '50s and '60s,
it was that same thing.
Oh, here is that guy
that I know,
and he's going to do
his stupid line again.
-The other thing I realized
watching it again is,
when I watch "Mad Men,"
I want to have a drink,
and when I watch "The Sopranos,"
I want a sandwich.
-Yeah. Right. Right.
-But, like, a sandwich that's,
like, wrapped in paper.
Like, you almost never even
see the sandwich.
I just like that part of it.
-I understand. I get it.
I get it.
-I also want to ask --
Obviously, you know
the show had --
You know, music was
a huge part of the show.
You know, Tony obviously
had music tastes that were very,
you know,
specific to his character.
I imagine they overlap with your
music tastes a great deal.
But, for me,
there are certain songs
that when I hear now,
my memory of them
is tied to moments in
"The Sopranos."
Like, when I hear "Glad Tidings"
by Van Morrison,
I think Tony Blundetto's
about to get it.
When I hear "Comfortably Numb,"
I know that's sort of
the end of Christopher.
And I'm wondering --
you put those songs there --
can you hear those songs without
thinking of those scenes?
-No, I can't.
I mean, I said something about
"Glad Tidings" the other day.
If you said to me
"Glad Tidings,"
I wouldn't necessarily
think about
Tony Blundetto getting shot.
If I heard it, I would.
I would,
because I was very proud.
I never thought we would get
Van Morrison to do anything,
and so I was really proud
and still am about that.
-And is that a situation
where you guys
had to reach out
and basically wait to see if
Van Morrison
would sign off on it?
-Well, yeah, but it wasn't
in the script.
It all -- That all comes during
post-production.
The show is put together,
and, you know,
we had been thinking about
musical things.
And -- I forget.
There was a -- there was a
contestant for that,
which was a Lou Reed song.
I don't remember the name,
but it was very close.
-You had another contestant
for "Don't Stop Believin'",
which obviously now will
forever be tied to the show,
because that's how it ended.
And "Don't Stop Believin'"
was not the crew's choice,
is this correct?
-No, the crew didn't like it.
I mean, we were
prepping the show
and we were riding around
in a location van.
It's about 12 people.
And I never did this
with the crew before.
But just to break
the tedium up, I said,
"Alan and I have been thinking
about the last song."
And I was serious.
"And I've got about
three contestants.
What do you guys think?"
"Oh, what are they?"
So I told them what
the first one was,
which was Al Green's song
"Love and Happiness."
"Well, I don't see
how that works in."
And then I said -- I forget
what the second one was.
And then I said
"Don't Stop Believin'".
They went, "Oh, Jesus, God, no.
How can you do that?
Don't do that. That's terrible.
That's horrible."
So, I said,
"Well, that's the one."
And I didn't -- I didn't do that
to be mean or --
I just thought,
"It is my favorite, actually,
and I think there's
something there."
It got such an emotional thing,
so, yeah, it was.
-Well, I think if
it's your favorite --
-Oh, and Steven Van Zandt was,
like -- Just wanted to shoot me.
-Really? Stevie was against it?
-Oh, totally.
Totally against it.
-We've been talking about him.
I feel like when that --
When the show started --
And, again, I don't --
You know, I don't remember
how I went into it.
I think that maybe
the premise of the show,
as it was pitched at the time
when it premiered on HBO,
was a little comic --
the idea of, like,
a mobster going to see
a therapist.
And Little Stevie, to me, seemed
like comic casting,
and then, as the show went on,
I forgot it was
Steven Van Zandt.
Like, he just became
Silvio to me.
Did he surpass your expectations
for what he would do
as an actor in that role?
-Well, it was great watching him
develop as an actor.
He was good
right from the first.
You've probably heard this,
that I thought --
I read him, we auditioned him,
and I thought maybe
he could be Tony.
And if he was Tony,
it would be a funny --
a different kind of show,
like a live-action "Simpsons"
or something.
And we took three guys there --
him and Jim and Michael Rispoli.
You know, and then once you see
Jim, it's like, you know,
"Alright, we're spending money
on this show, okay?
We are spending millions of
dollars on this show.
It's got to be somebody
who's acted in a series before."
So, yeah, it was pretty evident.
-I don't want to
steal your thunder,
because, again,
I love the prequel,
but I did write a prequel to
"The Sopranos" before you.
-Oh.
-I wrote an "SNL" sketch called
"The Sopranos Diaries."
-I remember that.
-There's Bobby Moynihan as Tony.
That's Bill Hader,
Fred Armisen, Kate McKinnon.
Did you see this sketch?
-I did. I did.
That was very funny.
-Alright.
-Yeah.
-I'm going to leave it there.
I don't really need --
-You wrote the whole thing?
-I wrote the whole thing
all by myself.
I mean, I feel like you did
a lot of the legwork.
I feel like, in a vacuum,
it wouldn't have worked
without "The Sopranos,"
so I guess co-wrote.
We co-wrote it.
-Alright. It was good.
-You know, the last thing --
You know, we had
Michael Gandolfini here.
You know, one of the,
really, most magnetic parts
about watching this prequel
is watching him play the part
that his father made so famous
and just on the level of
mannerisms that are the same.
But, you know, one of the things
he told me is that
you had to tell him to be
a little bit less angry
in the scenes.
Was that an effort
to make sure you left room
for the character to develop
to who we saw
in the television show?
-You know, I really don't
remember that conversation,
but it might have been he wasn't
so good at being angry.
It could have been that.
But there had to be some
headroom, somewhere to go
toward the end of the movie.
I think that's what it was.
-Well, he's fantastic.
The film is fantastic.
And thanks so much
for making time for us, David.
I really appreciate
talking to you.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-"The Many Saints of Newark"
is in theaters and on HBO Max.